[Music]
cassandra a wide column store nosql
database famous for its ability to
distribute petabytes of data with
unmatched reliability and performance it
was created in 2008 by avinash lakshman
who was responsible for scaling
facebook's inbox search feature by 2010
it became a top-level apache project and
today is used at scale by big companies
like apple which manages a staggering
100 petabytes of data across hundreds of
thousands of server instances it's a
general purpose database with use cases
for e-commerce content management audit
logging and everything in between each
instance of cassandra is called a node
and typically stores about two terabytes
of data what makes it special though is
that nodes can be easily distributed to
scale horizontally every node has the
same read write capabilities of another
node but is responsible for its own
partition of data nodes are grouped
together in a cluster or ring and data
is typically replicated on multiple
nodes which means no single point of
failure and 100 uptime the data is
wrapped in a key space giving developers
control over how it replicates in the
cluster each key space contains one or
more tables which represent tabular data
like you might find in a relational
database however it's schema-less and
can handle unstructured data which
developers can manage with the cassandra
query language the easiest way to get
started is by creating a free serverless
database with astra it deploys to the
cloud of your choice then scales
automatically on demand first we'll need
to define a key space which acts as a
container for replication next we'll
need to connect to the database which
can be accomplished in a variety of ways
it has sdks for major languages and a
tool called stargate that makes data
accessible via ras graphql and grpc or
you can execute raw cql code which is a
subset of sql create a table and include
a primary key to uniquely identify every
row then each column will have its own
name and data type now add data to that
table with the insert into statement
then you select to read data from the
table it's also possible to use the
where clause to filter and query the
data but an index will be required on
the column on the surface this may look
a lot like a relational database but it
doesn't support joins and that's by
design instead of modeling data into
small normalized tables in cassandra
it's denormalized to match the structure
of known queries making reads much
faster at scale and it's also possible
to implement storage attached indexing
to handle complex relational queries
this has been cassandra in 100 seconds
let me know if you want to see a full
tutorial in the comments thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one